over the past two decades the U.S has
made extraordinary progress in the fight
against AIDS and experts say that this
has happened in large part because of
President George W Bush's emergency plan
for AIDS relief it was called pepfar
It's a program that has cost more than a
hundred billion dollars but it has saved
more than 25 million lives aids-related
fatalities are now down 68 percent since
their Peak back in 2004. pepfar is the
largest commitment of any country ever
to fight a single disease and it is now
up for reauthorization by Congress this
year Dr Deborah Burks led the
implementation of pepfar programs as U.S
Global AIDS coordinator who also
remember her as the coronavirus response
coordinator in the first year of the
covet pandemic she is now a senior
fellow at the George W bush Institute Dr
Burks good morning to you thank you very
much for being here
um you know with advancements in science
and medicine a diagnosis and AIDS
diagnosis is no longer a death sentence
and yet you say we still need to
prioritize uh this fight why do you say
that
well for two reasons and I think your
lead-in from the California study is
California's story is such a great
lead-in because it shows that compassion
by individuals changed the life of an
individual and how did it change because
they acted they didn't just talk about
it they actually acted and saw the total
needs of that individual and that's what
pepfar was about it's about seeing the
total needs of the of the pandemic and
responding in a comprehensive way and
this is the first time that the U.S
translated money and people into an act
of compassion and we have shown that you
can change the course of a pandemic and
I think that's what gave me hope and
still gives me hope today that we can
continue to change courses of pandemics
around the world
Dr Burks when it comes to the
reauthorization of pepfarb do you
believe that our political climate is
strong enough to push through an
initiative like this right now
well what peffer taught us is if you
want to do something big as President
Biden just said in recognizing 20 years
of pepfar and there's a live stream
today starting at nine o'clock from the
bush Institute that really goes through
what pepfar has done but when President
Biden can talk about an initiative done
by a Republican president with respect
that's how we work to do big things as a
country whether it's domestically or
globally and so yes I think there will
be reauthorization because I think
Congress we've done this through 11
congresses with excellent support but I
think as a country we have to understand
if you want to do something big if you
want to do something that has an impact
that transcends political parties you
have to work in a bipartisan way
and that's why I know pepfar will be
reauthorized
Dr Burks just just Baseline of force
where are we in the fight and two I know
there is a goal to uh end the pan to end
uh the threat of AIDS by 2030. so how
will we get there considering where we
are now well as as you said in the
lead-in you use science and technology
but most importantly you use granular
data on the ground where you treat every
new infection as a failure of your
programming and when you do that and you
see the individuals that are impacted
and acquire HIV then you put programs in
place that prevent those new
acquisitions of infections and that has
been enormously successful but for every
success that you have with a population
or a community you can see the
individuals you've left behind and that
is absolutely critical I wish we were
doing that today with covid treating
these 300 to 500 deaths a day as a
failure of our programming because when
you do that you see what the issues are
and you fix them
Dr Burks I want to shift altitude here
kind of pull back and talk about trust
and faith in science in general because
the coveted pandemic has certainly
taught us that people lack both of those
things in this country and I'm curious
what you think needs to be done to
restore them
I think you have to get into the
community you cannot sit in Washington
or Atlanta and just put up commercials
and and public service analysis
announcements you need to get into the
community and really hear from them and
listen to them just like you did with
the California case you listen to what
his needs were and you addressed his
needs we're not addressing the needs of
the communities that are maximally
impacted with covet and we're not
addressing those that are significant
risk even today we're not addressing the
issues at tribal nations in our rural
communities and our disenfranchised
individuals instead we just say we're
just reassuring ourselves that they're
not listening that's our job as public
health officials to get on the ground
and figure out what we're doing wrong
and fix it you cannot do it from
Washington or Atlanta
uh but as Tony mentioned the covid
pandemic White House announced that the
covet related Public Health Emergency
declarations will expire in May is that
the right call
well you have to look what we're losing
and what was going to be put in its
place and I think what's important is we
have to get into the communities that
are still dying we've lost already about
five percent of Americans over 65. we've
lost 1.1 million Americans I don't
consider that a success if that was
happening with pepfar we would consider
that a crisis and we would work to fix
it and that's why today with the
disenfranchised groups that still exist
around the world we need to improve our
policies and our human rights to ensure
that we're reaching everyone that
applies globally and it applies here in
the United States so despite the ending
of the emergency we need to dig in and
do the hard Community work to ensure we
bring people back to the table
yeah Dr Brooks we're going to leave it
there for now uh as the 2024 campaign uh
heats up though we will of course be
relitigating a lot of what happened
during the Kobe pandemic uh through a
political lens so we'll talk more then
I'm sure thank you thank you